le 30 octobre 1938 les états unis
subissent une attaque extraterrestre
mais en fait non là c'est plutôt ont
subi un texte littéraire à la radio en
octobre 1938 un jeune acteur dans la
vingtaine
orson welles décide d'adapter un texte
très connu à l'époque de hadji world war
of the worlds la guerre des mondes qui
doivent roman de science fiction il lui
il décide de l'adapter comme un bulletin
de nouvelles
si retransmis à la radio mais le
lendemain il ya des journaux qui
commencent à tirer qu'une panique
une hystérie collective dans différentes
rues des villes aux états unis ça va
aller plus loin on va même interrogé
olsen wars sur le pourquoi de ses
motivations
deux ans plus tard en 1940 un
psychologue anglicane free a publié une
étude dans laquelle il révèle justement
les formes de la psychose nationale
compris cet événement que l'on dit ça y
est les jeunes y ont cru pour vrai sauf
que quelques années plus tard un
sociologue pierre lagrange publié une
étude qui révèle les dessous de ce que
kendry analyser la grange des montres en
croisant avec d'autres sources de
l'époque qui oppose eu de panique ni
d'hystérie collective
tout ça c'est une construction des
médias et plus spécifiquement des
journaux mais pourquoi les journaux ont
agi de cette manière là bas il faut
rappeler que dans les années 30 et 40 et
un nouveau médium qu'on appelle la radio
et s'attaque directement aux monopoles
qui avait les journaux donc les journaux
vont tâcher de discréditer la radio en
montrant justement les excès de ce faux
reportage d'or chinoise
bref une fausse nouvelle des fausses
informations pour essayer de discréditer
un immédiat
ça ressemble à aujourd'hui ce coin
[Musique]